okay so hello we are going to be talking
about understanding iterators and
iterables in javascript by a show of
hands how many of you write JavaScript
day-to-day ooh a good number of you how
many of you write Python okay because
some of the stuff we're gonna talk about
here is actually you already have it in
Python and we just got it in JavaScript
as of es6 so you're gonna actually
recognize some of the stuff that I'm
talking about too but I've already been
introduced but again I'm Jen you can
reach out to me online at girl code girl
with you and I am a senior front-end
engineer at a company called Rent the
Runway
who knows about Rent the Runway mostly
the women that is no surprise to me we
rent fabulous gowns to women for events
and then we also have a every day
subscription I'm wearing it right now
okay so I write JavaScript every day in
my job so I like to think of myself as
less of a JavaScript engineer and more
of a JavaScript detective because a lot
of the time javascript does some like
surprising things that I'm like what
like what are you doing and that's what
I really like to dig in and try and
understand why it's doing the thing that
it's doing so the most recent mystery
that I had to solve was about the spread
operator now the spread operator if
you're not familiar with it or you
aren't familiar with JavaScript is new
as of es6 so relatively new to the
language es6 was a big addition to the
language and the spread operator you
mostly are gonna see it used with a race
and what it's doing is you have your
lovely array we're gonna put some values
in that lovely array and then you get to
use the spread operator with that array
and what is essentially doing the spread
operators it's taking each value out of
the array and then spreading it out into
a comma-separated list like this and so
you can use this to spread out values in
an array into another array and you can
also use the spread operator to gather
value
into an array so we're gonna do some
live coding and we're gonna see how this
Mearing shortcut goes okay and then I
think I have to get out of here
there we go okay so if we're gonna do
this array it's a little bit easier to
show this than to actually just talk
about it with you what we want to do is
we're gonna spread out the arrays into
console dot log and I think this will be
fine okay okay and so you can see down
there that we've actually individually
we've sent in one two and three as a
comma separated list to console dot
block and then if we wanted to we could
spread it out into another array so in
this case like so you can see I've now
put all those values into an actually
different array and then if we're doing
a function we can do a spread operator
inside of the arguments and we're gonna
see what that does for us so if I call
this again with one two and three you
can see it's gathered all of the
arguments and put them into an array for
me so the spread operator is already
very very handy in JavaScript for
getting values out at array copying them
into another array or using them to
gather arguments in a function but you
know it's used for a raise it can also
be used for a string and you know
actually this kind of makes sense
because strings in JavaScript you can
sort of treat them like arrays like if I
want to get out the a here I could do
this string saved to a variable and then
ask for its 0th index and I would get to
a so in some cases like this actually
kind of makes sense because it's like an
array
already so of course the spread operator
works on it but then I saw this and this
is where my brain was like uh what
you're doing so again I said like if you
work on Python this is gonna be really
familiar to you because you guys already
have generators we got them in es6
officially though we technically have
had them in Chrome and some browsers for
a while but we got an official spec for
them in es6 and if you don't understand
why this is really weird and your face
is like what um let's go over generators
real quick and then you'll understand
why this is really strange so this is a
generator and I know it's a generator
because it has an asterisk next to the
function key word and inside that
generator you're also going to see a
special statement called yield and yield
in a generator means pause to use the
generator we're going to call it so in
this case we call it and then we get
back a generator object and that
generator object has on it a method
called next when you call next you're
gonna get back an object with two keys
on it the value and done value is
whatever is to the right that you want
to send back on the yield statement so
you can see yield one and my value is
one and then done is gonna tell you the
status of the generator so if it's done
or not and in this case it's not because
there's more statements to run so if we
keep calling next then we're gonna keep
getting values and we don't actually
have to yield any values if we don't
want to yield just means pause you don't
have to give it a value next to it so
what its gonna do is it'll just be value
undefined in that case and each time
that you're calling next here and you're
yielding it is a true pause most of the
JavaScript that I write is really run to
completion once I start the program it's
not gonna pause at any point you can do
some async work but that's really
throwing something on to the event loop
and it's just gonna come back around but
with generators you're actually pausing
the code so when you see a yield
statement it's actually truly pausing
and this function isn't gonna run again
until I tell it to
by calling next so if we call next again
real ding three value three still not
done
now we call next again it goes back and
enters the generator again and sees that
there's nothing else to be done
so our done is actually true and again
we're not yielding any final value here
so values undefined now you can also
pass information into a generator via
yield so you know this looks a little
bit odd at first when you're looking at
it because like okay I did yield I did
yield and I'm doing generator next but
I'm actually passing the value into the
second call to next why is it not the
first one well the first time that you
call next on the generator you're really
starting it up and you're telling it
basically just run until you see a yield
statement and then pause and so actually
there's nothing for this generator to do
until it hits that first yield statement
so I'm calling next when I'm starting up
the generator it sees that yield
statement in the assignment expression
and it pauses and you can see this is a
true pause because it's not assigning
anything yet then I'm gonna pass the
number to it and now it's gonna take the
place of where that yield previously won
and now it's actually going to get
assigned to Const done and then when I
yield again now we're actually doing a
number to the side of that so we pause
but we also are sending back two plus
two so now we're getting value for and
then when I call this again we've set
number four
so we're yielding six this time then
we're done and it really another like
very interesting thing is about
generators is that you can run
generators from inside other generators
and you're gonna do so using the yield
star expression so to illustrate this I
have a generator called outer and a
generator called inner and as you can
see outer is calling inner and again
we're gonna be calling out our getting
its generator object and then we're
going to be starting it up and here it
runs until it hits yield and then it's
gonna pass back one all right now we're
actually hitting that new generator
though you
the old star expression and what's
happening here is a bit different
because we're actually going inside of
that generator so yield star acts as a
delegate and now every time that next
gets called it's actually calling next
on this inner generator it's just that
you didn't have to go through and plot
out all the different calls to next
within this outer generator you're using
yield star and so it's gonna naturally
just do this for you so now we call next
again we're still inside of the inner
generator so our value is B and we're
still not done and then when we call the
next again we're gonna go back to the
outer so this is a way of iterating
through these generators with yield star
and you don't have to worry about
calling next on them and now you might
be able to see why this seems kind of
weird because the spread operator works
with arrays and it works with strings
and they kind of have a similar
structure in that they have indexes that
it can go through but what is it doing
with the generator is it calling next on
it like how is it running it if I have
to manually put in next like what is the
spread operator doing with this and as
it turns out you can use a spread
operator with anything that is an
iterable in JavaScript and generators
are iterables so our arrays and so our
strings maps and sets which are new data
structures as of es6 and javascript are
also iterables so you can use a spread
operator with any of these and it'll
actually spread out the values from it
now we didn't actually have much of a
concept of an iterable before es6 like
you could do it eration of course but we
didn't actually have a protocol for you
to use so an interval is a data
structure that's going to provide an
interface for iteration what does that
mean it means it's gonna use the new
iterable protocol so this is new as of
es6 there's an actual protocol for these
things what this protocol says is that
you're going to use a special key and an
object to turn it into an iterable that
special key is called symbol iterator
symbol
is also new to es6 it's a new primitive
and it's kind of produce an anonymous
unique value so here we're using symbol
and I'm using the keyword key and it's
gonna generate a new symbol for me and
again this is anonymous and a unique
value and you can use symbol in your own
code but it's also used internally in
JavaScript so an array is an interval
because it puts in place the iterable
protocol which says that at the key
symbol iterator you're going to provide
back and iterator so if you go to array
dot prototype and you request its symbol
dot iterator you're gonna see a function
there and the same for string and the
same for generators so these all have
iterators that live on them at this key
the iterator is actually the object
that's going to implement the iterator
protocol so there's the iterable
protocol and the iterator protocol the
iterable protocol tells you how to set
up an object that's going to point to an
iterator and then the iterator protocol
is going to tell you what you actually
need to do to match the iteration
protocol that would be expected of say
the spread operator or anything else
that wants to use that protocol so to do
that you're going to create a function
and it needs to return an object with a
next method on it which is going to
return an object with a value and a
dunkey and we've already seen this
because generators implement the
iterator protocol and so we've actually
already learned this by the time we get
to this point like we've already seen
you call get an object get back the next
method and then call that to get the
done and the value so if you call the
fake iterator you get back the object
with the next method and you call next
so you get value and done and because we
know all of this we can create our own
so we're going to be creating an
irritable iterator
it's going to be quite angry that is the
plan okay this alright so Oh pray to the
live coding gods that this is all gonna
be fine okay so we're gonna create our
iterator function now we're gonna have
to keep track of where we are so in this
case not constant we're gonna do a step
that we're going to increment and then
we're going to return our object with
the next method on it okay okay and now
what we're going to do is we're going to
make sure that we increment the step
cool that's done and then we're going to
side what we want to do if the step is
something in particular right so in this
case if the step equals one we are going
to return an object with a value
and done is gonna be false in this case
because we're not done yet and trying to
remember what is it yes okay
I remembered the shortcut for this but
they don't use it very often okay so the
first time our iterator is gonna be like
not super happy with us and then we're
just gonna progressively annoy it so
what we're gonna do I'm just gonna do
some quick copy and paste so when it
stepped to and went step 3 we're going
to change the emoji so that it gets
progressively you know mad at us okay so
now we got a red face and now we're
gonna have him Oh Kirsten oh oh this is
iterators mad okay
so now we have this and is this big
enough for everyone to see you I make it
any bigger a little bigger someone has
requested I don't know if it's gonna
there we go
okay better great alright so we have our
iterator we have our step or plus
plussing our step and then depending on
what step we're on we're gonna return
something else
ooh and if we're done we are going to
return value undefined and done will be
true great
we're going to call this iterator and
then I'm going to use the spread
operator I'll take it right woman do
this okay
ooh we have an error what did I do wrong
does anyone know
let's see I have the iterator I have my
step I am returning an object do I need
oh no I don't need to call fake iterator
someone else said something though
something about parens
oh you think one of these is extra yeah
maybe let's see nope that should be fine
let me call it a log oh dear that does
always work and let me comment this out
so at least what we should have here is
yeah we are going back oh okay um it
should be calling next step equals one
this is all fine um okay well if I do
fake iterator dot next and I save that
let me do structure this ending out the
value we're gonna get out done and then
instead of using the spread operator
here it should return the right items to
me okay so yeah so it's returning like
angry face and false and then if we
called NEX again that should also work
[Music]
if I do console dialog with the spreader
operator though it should have iterated
through it
what parentheses after the fake iterator
oh you mean like this no no the reason
that you don't need to do that is
because you're actually going to be
calling dot next on the fake iterator so
you only call the fake iterator one time
which is here and that returns to you
the object with the next method on it so
actually there's nothing else for you to
call except the next method and I don't
know what I've done wrong to make this
angry at me no you don't have to put the
star no yield star is only for when
you're doing another generator which I
will show you later
look see it said found non callable
iterator and I'm guessing it's because
I've already called it on line 24
oh but you know what maybe I don't know
that's not gonna work oh this is the one
that's having the problem right okay
yeah it's keep saying it's a non
callable iterator okay well in any case
this bread wrapper should work it I
don't know what I'm doing wrong here but
that's okay so every time we call dot
next we're gonna get the next thing
until it's done so what the spread up or
should be doing here that I can't figure
out what I have done wrong is it should
be going through each time on the
iterator it's actually going to call
next on the iterator each time so
because the spread operator is using the
iteration protocol to loop through
things it's actually calling dot next on
this so one of the other things we're
gonna do which
if this is correct and some reason it's
my setup that's not working this should
work if not I have a gif of it somewhere
I'm still looking for mistakes I'm like
I know something's not right here
it should be Const if it's constant
actually can't reassign it you use it on
iterables but when I did oh shoot that's
what I did
I know what I did wrong so I have the
iterator here but I'm dumb and I forgot
to actually assign it that's what I did
wrong that jogged my memory thank you
okay so here's what's going on that I
just totally blanked on because live
coding is not my thing okay is that we
actually have to save it to this or else
it's not an iterable so this is very
instrumental actually as much as this
was a faux pas it actually illustrates
it like you can't actually use the
spread operator if you don't make it a
true iterable which means it has to be
part of the iterable protocol and the
protocol says you have to save it on
this key so if I do this and now I
console dot log irritable because it's
made now it works
so obviously my offering to the live
coding gods like wasn't enough but
that's okay okay so what we're gonna do
now is we have this same thing same
iterator so that is totally actually
fine but what we're gonna do is we're
gonna hack the array prototype I'm like
am i misspelled and everything now okay
so same thing Italy has this on it but
we're going to hack it so we can't
actually do this in my editor because
apparently node has like some sort of
like security something I don't know it
doesn't like when you mess with the
array prototype so we're gonna do it
actually here and then once we've done
this
it might yell at me yeah it's gonna yell
at me because I didn't put it in Nuri ah
so now it's angry all the time so no
matter what I'm putting into this array
because I've messed with its iteration
I've actually overridden its iterator
when you try to use the spread operator
with any array that you create it
doesn't matter you know what's inside of
it or how long it is when I use it it's
just gonna give me a lot of a lot of
anger
it's just mad now this is a lot of fun
to do by the way and I really encourage
you to do this to your co-workers and
just see how long it takes them like
what's going on here
and I've had a lot of fun with this but
this is a clear understanding of like
how you can overwrite the array
prototypes iterator and do this kind of
like fun thing now this doesn't actually
affect other things though so if you
were doing for each or you're mapping or
filtering or anything like that
it's not using the iteration protocol so
you're gonna get the same values this is
really just for the spread operator and
there are a couple other methods that
are gonna use this if we do a raid out
from and sorry I forgot to put this up
higher for y'all
I apologize then it's actually going to
be copying from the iterator not the
values that are in the array so you
would expect this to put a string ABC
inside of the new array a readout from
copies and array and puts its values
into a new array but it's using the
iteration protocol and since we over
wrote that to only send us angry emojis
that's all we're gonna get now this is
also true of some other things in
JavaScript some stuff that you might use
so for instance
for up so I believe if I just do
irritable this will work and then let me
comment okay so for of uses the
iteration protocol as well so you can
see here that it's still just looping
through and getting all the values some
other stuff that uses this is also
destructuring in JavaScript so if you
wanted to if you want to get like the
first value and then you're going to
gather up your other values I think I'd
have to run this if this one should work
maybe no you know I have to do for this
one to work I'd have to create a new
array let me go back to my if I do first
let me just do this real quick
with fun
all right so you can see I'm
destructuring
from an array that technically if I'm D
structuring the first thing from this
array it should be that ABC string but
since D structuring actually uses the
iteration protocol and we've written it
we're actually going to get the first
angry emoji so actually a lot of things
that we use in JavaScript pretty much
every day at this point since es6 gave
us all these capabilities is actually
based off of the iteration protocol so
we made we made this all angry that was
good that was fun
okay now the other thing that's really
interesting that is newer is not
included in es6 but is coming up and is
available in most browsers at this point
is async iteration so in this case
you're actually going to be able to
create an iterator that returns promises
and it's part of actually using async
await now this is a little bit different
because to create this we're actually
going to put it on the async iterator
key instead of just the iterator key and
this of course means that it's going to
be in asynchronous iterator
okay so get rid of this you can save it
this alright so what I have here is that
I have a bunch of emoji just random
emoji that I've put into an object with
key value pairs that's all fine and then
over here what I have is a function
called weight and weight is just a
promise that doesn't resolve until this
set timeout that I'd like put in what
milliseconds I want it to to resolve so
that's my weight and then I just have a
random function that's gonna give me a
random number up to a max and then here
we have the get emoji request and so you
can see that this is a sync and it's
using a weight so in JavaScript now you
can create async functions and then
you're gonna use the await keyword to
actually wait for something to resolve
so in this case remember that weight is
a promise that only resolves when that
set timeout is finished so we're going
to actually at that portion just like
kind of wait until we actually finish
things and it's just like to basically
make this look more asynchronous and
then we're gonna return an emoji using
whatever we requested so what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna create an
async generator so we could create an
async iterator on our own like we just
did a custom iterator but generators are
already doing this for us
you know it's kind of annoying to go
create your own custom iterators unless
you really need them when generators are
already available for you so we're gonna
create an async generator instead and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna yield
get emoji and then inside of get emoji
we're going to yield here so we get to
decide what we're gonna pass in so we're
gonna call a Sikh gentleman
and then we're gonna call generator dot
next to start this up now again when you
start up a generator the first time
you're just gonna call dot next and
that's gonna start it but it's actually
like not going to it's not gonna
actually be able for us to like passing
something initially with this so if I
wanted the gemstone emoji like this is
not going to get that for me in fact we
can run it and we can do constant value
and you'll see that it's going to be
it's gonna be undefined so see it's
undefined because we're just running the
generator were just telling it to go
ahead and start up and do do whatever
you need to do before you see the first
yield statement and honestly there's
just nothing for this to do but the
second time we call this we actually can
request something now so the first time
you know isn't gonna do anything that's
fine but the second time we are going to
request the gemstone but because this is
asynchronous what we actually have to do
is we're going to do dot then on it so
every time now that you're gonna yield
something because this is an async
generator it's going to return a promise
to you and so then you get to call then
on this we're gonna do structure the
value here the console dot log about you
and as you can see there's kind of a
wait until it gets the value for you so
if we were to do another one
you see it's waiting and then it gets it
so it's only waiting a certain amount of
time but this is an async generator now
some of the fun stuff you can do with
this is what I've built here is an async
generator called random emoji stream and
what this is gonna do is it takes all of
my emojis and it uses the random
function that I called before we give it
the max of how many keys are actually in
that object so it will only grab the
ones from zero to that length and then
it's gonna yield one of the emojis it's
gonna do this every second so we're
gonna use a new syntax called for a
weight to call this one so since this is
a stream and we're continuously going to
get emojis from this we're going to use
this syntax to iterate going through the
generator but also waiting for values
but
and then we'll just console.log oh yes
and also kind of forgot about this you
have to do this inside of an async
function or else you can't use a weight
it'd be nice if you could use it on your
own but you do need to use it inside of
an async function or else it yells at
you
which is fine I mean our iterator yelled
at us a bunch so I'm used to it by now
okay and what do we want to call this I
guess emoji e-reader okay and we're
going to console dot log the emoji and
then we are going to call emoji reader
and something went wrong love it it's
not an async iterable oh I think I need
to actually yep okay so now you see
every one second we're gonna get a new
random emoji so this stream is providing
data for us and then using for await
inside of an async function we're
actually reading that data and get to do
something with it now I think I've done
enough life coding for now so I'm not
gonna do any more but you know this is
really useful for if you have streams of
data and you need to start doing like
pipeline processing with it because this
allows you to do that and one of the
great things that you get out of this is
the ability to read your code a little
bit more clearly when it comes to async
code because everything that we're doing
here if I did this with just callbacks
holy hell and if I did this with just
promises Jesus know you know promises
are really great but when you're doing
like a lot of async work like this
especially pipeline work this doesn't
work as well so that was tons of fun and
we're gonna go back to the real world
now which is my presentation okay so you
know that was us looking at everything
in the inner like raider world like how
to create an iterator what an iterable
even is how the spread operator works
with them but you might also note that
in JavaScript the spread operator
works with objects - and objects by
themselves aren't iterables you have to
make them an interval like I did earlier
when I used our sample iterator and
combined it using the symbol dot
iterator keyword so that will actually
take an object and make it into an
interval but by default they aren't
still you can use them if you want to
now instead of using the interval
protocol if you want to use the spread
operator with an object it's gonna take
all the keys and values out of an object
you can place them inside of another
object it's super useful as a
replacement for object out of sine but
in the spec it's just not using the
interval protocol anymore the spec for
this is actually very different so you
might see these being used in code and
be like oh it's using the interval
protocol it's not it's actually a
completely different spec but it is
totally useful and all of this just
makes me love intervals and the spread
operator like even more there's so much
you get to do with it and I was really
happy to dive in and understand all
these things that are coming out and
JavaScript that used these protocols as
well as very clearly understanding you
know what doesn't so thank you all for
your time I hope you had fun how to take
questions now
[Applause]
yes so so for some reason on my local
machine running node against that exact
same code kept producing an error that
was it's not a number and I was like
okay I don't know what you want but I'm
guessing you're mad about me overriding
the array.prototype because you work
perfectly when I'm creating just a
random iterable so yeah I think they
might have something going on where
they're not quite ready for me to do
that sort of hacking in node but in the
browser totally fine oh you can totally
do anything in the browser all right I
don't see any more questions so oh we
have one yeah I did you want to know
about that sure yeah okay so I'm a big
user of react how many of you all use
react good number yay so I really love
react it's it's like my my chosen
framework I've used it for for you know
four plus years and one of the things
that I did over the past year was I
actually started diving into the fibre
reconciler codebase so react has a
reconciler that tells you what parts of
your application have changed and allow
you to make minimal updates to the Dom
to make those changes onto the screen
that reconciler was rewritten a couple
years ago
and it's actually really interesting
because it's making a lot of changes so
we recently did a screen recording with
Dan Abramov he is on the react core team
at Facebook very well-known he is also
the creator behind Redux if you've used
that library and what Dan was
essentially doing was we came up with a
silly concept for him to implement into
the reconciler and then he walked us
through how he would actually do that so
it's a way of starting to get used to
what that codebase looks like what the
different parts of it are how they've
you know chunked up the different
sections according to the different
phases of reconciliation and
particularly helpful if you want to you
know take down the codebase and start
looking at it yourself and you know
maybe you want to contribute maybe you
just are really curious about some of
the stuff that happens it's a great
screencast it's coming out soon yes it
does
he's coming with the microphone just so
everyone can hear they're still
proposals but they will be in the
upcoming language but they are already
implemented in Chrome and I believe also
Firefox
uh I only really have Twitter which is
nice because you get to see things like
the revolving TV in my hotel room why
it's there I don't know but yeah I'm I'm
on twitter i speak prolifically at
conferences so I posted a lot of slides
and sometimes I post like I did post a
gif of me turning the array and the
browser the prototype into a mad array
so you can definitely follow me on
twitter at girlcode and keep up with me
there but I don't have like a website
blog podcast anything like that
thank you thank you everyone
[Applause]